racontez-nous concept est en train de
vivre une nouvelle situation
la cabine business et la bolivie on le
sait c'est un pays très vulnérables qui
n'ont pas accès à l'océan à la mère qui
la situe dans une situation très
particulière aussi donc donné nos
données nous un petit peu de contexte de
ce que vous vivez dans le contexte de la
coved à 19 ans seulement dans la bolivie
par ses parfums bon mais d'abord
parlement aussi juste et spécifiques que
notre programme mais voit aussi le pérou
donc je peux aussi parler un petit peu
de ce qui se passe au pérou puis ce qui
se passe dans les deux pays vont
l'amérique latine en général et commune
très touché par la crise bovine monde de
cars mais aussi au niveau et de l'impact
que ça sonne tout le monde sur la
population au niveau du nombre de cas
c'est sûr que le pérou et est parmi les
pays qui ont plus augmenté dans les
dernières semaines donc très rapidement
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de cas et et on
veut diviser un peu plus restreint au
niveau des cols donc je pense que
justement ce que vous mentionnez le fait
que ce soit un pays qui soit un peu plus
isolés qui sont un peu moins connectée
est bon au moins deux vols
internationaux il ya beaucoup moins de
direction avec avec lequel du monde
finalement ça a peut-être un peu joué en
notre faveur dans le sens où on ne le
moins que audi plus importés donc ça
fait en sorte que plus entre les et
surtout des autorités mais ça c'est en
évoquant bonnet j y perd rapidement à
dire qu'ils ont déclaré la quarantaine
la totale et complète et dès le début
donc pour le pérou avant c'était au tour
du 7 mars pour la bolivie le 21 mars
on est tombé en quarantaine en tête mais
les français auront été fermé et tous
les vols ont été constatés à la mi mars
ils ont agi rapidement et dans le cas de
vie c'est entre autres parce que bon je
pense qu'ils savent très bien qu'on ne
peut pas se permettre d'avoir une telle
magnitude
parce qu'on ne peut pas les
infrastructures ni social et on ne peut
pas l'infrastructure de santé non plus
pour répondre à cette crise là donc
la solution a rapidement été on ferme
tout y'a rien qui va pouvoir compléter
mais malgré tout on a quand même on ne
va quand même eu une certaine évolution
là des mous et on a quand même des
plusieurs centaines malgré tout ce qui
est complètement contrôlé et on est en
quarantaine complète et totale et
complète et totale c'est qu'on a on a
comme au canada où on peut sortir 30 de
marche où on peut aller faire du sport
le faire un jogging au parc
ici c'est une sortie entre 7h et 12h
pour aller faire les courses de base
ouvrier plus sinon c'est tout le monde à
la maison et le contrôle policier et les
ans d'armée et à ses effectifs
mais bon on a vu quand même qu'il ya eu
des débordements il ça a été très
difficile et la quarantaine donc dans
plusieurs raisons droits sur tous les
marchés les marchés populaires ya eu
quand même les débris de la quarantaine
mais ils ont ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont
pu pour la faire pour la faire vivre ma
passion questions concernant justement
le travail sur le terrain les trains que
vous faites
on s'est calé population générale
d'allemandes surtout dans les pays les
plus pauvres mais avec des plus de
détours de défavorisation c'est encore
plus important
doubler les effets de cette épidémie de
cette pandémie
mais au niveau de votre travail sur le
terrain en tant que organisations
humanitaires canadiennes en bolivie
comme un sas et comment ça s'articule
comme un quels sont les défis les plus
importants en ce moment dans ce cadre là
oui mais c'est sûr que écouter et à deux
niveaux je voudrais qu'on voit vraiment
déjà les impacts mais on travaille
beaucoup ici en bolivie et au pérou
travaille beaucoup avec les personnes
handicapées
mais c'est sûr qu'avec les personnes
handicapées en ce moment on voit
énormément d'impact sur leur vie et sur
le terrain ça décline un plan en deux en
deux types d'impacts je voudrais et
pentax la santé évidemment et en ce
moment les actions des personnes
handicapées est vraiment d'équipé parce
que souvent c'est des personnes qui
peuvent avoir des maladies chroniques
qui sont liées à leur handicap etc des
personnes qui nécessitent des soins de
santé des suivis et en ce moment peuvent
pas aller à leurs séances de
réadaptation par exemple comme
raisonnable on commence à voir des
graves problèmes d'accès aux médicaments
et donc il ya des gens qui doivent
prendre des médicaments tous les jours
et qu'ils ne sont plus capables d'avoir
accès à leurs médicaments s'était
également dans les dernières semaines
d'appel par appareil et donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de préoccupant
et puis est ce ton est essentiellement
dans une situation doublement plus plus
marqué et fille sont plus exposés parce
que finalement la distanciation sociale
ou disais que c'est compliqué quand tu
as besoin que quelqu'un qui tapis dans
ses activités quotidiennes de handicap
donc et ça rend les choses très
compliquées
et quand ils utilisent une aide
technique donc un appui technique donc
que tu dois t'assurer que tu devras
pleine implication et au niveau de la
santé des gens et puis oui les personnes
qui ont des complications par rapport à
leur handicap donc des maladies
chroniques sont plus à risque d'avoir
des complications de l'aco vide
donc en plus d'exposer pour ça c'est
définitivement un aspect et puis un
autre pilier en fait depuis pour
l'instant si celui sur lequel on a réagi
le plus rapidement comme organisation
comme mannequin fusion parce que la
vulnérabilité socio-économique que c'est
en train qui est donc très rapidement où
on sait on connaît les gens avec une
population avec qui on travaille
habituellement sur des projets plus de
développement on sait que quand on entre
dans une période et de cuisine comme ça
qui est ça me permet aussi une crise
économique et socio économique d'une
certaine façon et c'est genre en partie
l'économie informelle c'est risqué
catégorique le niveau d'emplois formels
des groupes venir donc entre les
personnes handicapées et on va devenir
vraiment très très bonne mondeville
chiffres totaux de 11% 6 très très bas
donc on sait que ces personnes là vivent
au jour le jour
on sait que ces personnes ne doit sortir
dans la rue du vent de certaines
certaines zidane qui leur permet de
sauver et ils ont ils ont vraiment ils
ont prennent vraiment un coup en ce
moment parce que on parle des besoins de
base qui sont peu couverts et c'est
aussi simple qu'il n'aime pas voir du
mount on est mort on ne peut pas la
capacité d'assurer que ces personnes ne
mangent tous les jours pendant la
quarantaine mais oui on a fait une
intervention au début un peu plus au
milieu puis la semaine prochaine parce
que là c'est une autre distribution
donc ceci je pensais la base qu'on qu'on
pouvait faire et qui nous a permis de
réagir rapidement et d'imagés est-ce que
vous pas comptait revenir au canada
bientôt où vous pensez vraiment respect
d'un contexte la quarantaine bolivienne
pour les semaines qui suivent à moi
c'est sûr que nous et on revient au
canada il faut qu'on soit ici notre
travail sur le terrain mission donc et
on s'est assuré
bon ça c'est vraiment que nos équipes
tant au pérou en bolivie 106 ans se
sentent sécurisées sont en sécurité on
n'expose pas nos équipes évidemment sa
sister on utilise tout le matériel qu'il
faut pourrait les protéger donc et qu'on
fait des distributions comme ça avec le
public on on s'organise pour que tout le
monde soit très bien protégé mais on est
ici pour eux pour s'assurer d'une
organisation humanitaire donc j'ai
besoin de bras pour être couvert
c'est certain donc nous on reste ici moi
je reste ici aussi je sais qu'elle est
par exemple en bolivie et au pérou les
canadiens qui n'est plus un titre
touristique qui était un peu pris ici
ils sont tous partis le week-end dernier
dans leur grande majorité l'ambassade a
fait beaucoup travaillent pour évacuer
faire des évacuations de ressortissants
canadiens les pays mais nous on sent
qu'ils sont couvertes par humanité
intuition canada parce que vous
travaillez vous êtes en colombie pardon
en bolivie puis au pérou
mais est ce que vous savez des contacts
avec les autres directions des problèmes
ailleurs dans le monde comme en bus
articulés votre travail aussi ailleurs
rapidement
oui bien sûr bien sûr et mais en fait
même conclusion au travail dans une
cinquantaine de langues 50 et 60 pays
vont ça change selon selon les
programmes qui fait à peu près 50 pays
actuellement
et puis oui c'est sûr qu'on en fait on
se parle chaque pays
en ce moment c'est pas chaque semaine
comprendre un peu ce qui se passe un peu
partout juste dans la région par exemple
nous on a beaucoup des liens avec ce qui
se passe en colombie et on a un
programme aussi à cuba
et puis sinon ben il n'est présent dans
énormément de pays d'afrique d'asie du
sud est donc par exemple il ya beaucoup
d'action en fait presque la presse que
l'entièreté des programmes actuellement
ont mis un peu de côté ce qu'ils
faisaient et de façon plus régulière
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on doive
faire aussi à cause des restrictions
mais l'idée ça a été de gérer et diriger
toutes les énergies qu'on pouvait dans
la commune
oui on a des réponses dépendamment aussi
des contextes un peu chacun par exemple
il a des cheveux il travaille
régulièrement dans les camps d g
d'héroïne gars donc ils ont une
intervention qui tout à fait différente
ils ont une population qui est
extrêmement de l'érable à la base et qui
doivent vraiment s'assurer que les
besoins
basés tous les jours donc ça rajoute une
couche de nécessité en fait de besoin m
mais bon chaque chaque rue chaque
programme un contexte différent on
adapte notre intervention par rapport à
ça donc je vous dirais que en plus
depuis ce jeudi de besoins pas pourquoi
attention à tout ce qui est formation
était vraiment en général presque tous
les programmes numériques inclusion
l'homme et en échangeant avec mes
collègues on se rend compte rapidement
tout ce qui est sensibilisation
s'assurer qu'un bonne information arrive
bon second est bio comme des mythes qui
se crée bon je pense que partout quand
même qu'à la veille des mes petites
filles il ya des fausses factures
rapidement ça se répandait des genres
donné par leur base et des forces
historiques sur des croyances
traditionnelles et je pense comme ça
donc tous les programmes dans ce moment
ça sur quelle information est bien reçu
elle est accessible et l'éclair elle est
vraiment vérifié et puis elle est
dirigée envers ces populations là aussi
et pour pour répondre à ses besoins
finalement donc c'est vraiment important
que les formations pour certains groupes
particulièrement de nairas soit soit
bien divulgué les marchés mais vous
savez les programmes en bolivie au pérou
pour humanité à une pulsion et on dit on
disait tout à l'heure la bolivie face à
cette pandémie de l'aco vite parce qu'il
ya vu les réalités socio économiques
importantes
donc merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
cette entrevue au réseau pénale
internationale merci